Hey!
What is up English learners from all over the
world?
I am Chad, one of the fluency coaches here
at RealLife English and Learn English with
TV Series, and today I have another hilarious
English lesson for you all based on a scene
from Friends.
So to really make the most out of this learning
opportunity and absorb the whole scene you
have to download the Power Lesson, which is
our learning guide which breaks down and explains
all the new vocabulary, idioms, expressions,
pronunciation, and the connected speech, the
way that English, native English speakers
actually speak, and the cultural references.
So explaining all the jokes, and those things
that don't translate very well from other
languages.
So download the guide and follow our watch,
study, watch method and you are going to be
amazed at how much more you understand by
the end of this lesson
sit back, relax, and enjoy this scene from
Friends.
Awww Yeah!!!